foreign
what's going on
I'm a I'm a truck driver that's my truck
right there because I was driving by
her on the ground okay and I've seen
that dude over there fucking soccer or
punch her in the face
so related to you
you got it for 16 years okay husband
wife or a boyfriend girlfriend boyfriend
girlfriend okay you want to press
charges yeah I do I wanna I just I just
pulled over to make sure she's okay do
you have a wife no I don't have a
lighter is he on anything
that you know of about that I know of no
but I'm done
for it I want to say God damn champ get
over it
and I haven't been driving I wasn't
driving he has my goddamn Keys okay I
was gonna go get a lighter for her so I
got units coming but smoking can you
ever secure him yeah why don't you go
ahead and stay here man
hello sir hello the chain behind your
back stay seated put your hands behind
your back okay
if it's
once you step up
see what's going on
you want anything
so we're starting to fight
alcohol
where were you hitting her
I did
you guys were in a mutual combated
your knife
that's it that's it
have you had anything to drink yes how
much
but I wasn't driving
I wasn't driving
oh someone had to drive to get here
don't say anything please she was
driving here
all right go ahead and put the cigarette
out I'm not okay
thank you
all ready to have a seat
until I figure out what's going on yes
sir yes sir all right yes sir I got
medical coming
yeah I just put it up there so I could
scare him in the back of my car
the sponge go by the Jeep
so what did you see sir
um
so as I was driving I seen her sitting
on the ground and dude if I could talk
back at either slap her or punch her and
like I got family you know what I'm
saying like I got sisters and stuff I
would never you know what I mean so I
pulled over I was ready to like you know
fight him really but uh he was calm and
so like when I walked over I that's my
trip right there
pointed that way yeah I walked over and
I was like hey are you okay and she's
like crying and stuff and then he was
trying to talk to me but I just wanted
to get in the middle of them too and so
she was like hey can you call the cops
and that's when I called the cops have
an idea on you sir it's in the truck
right if you can get it for me I
appreciate it we go check on her
thank you
well he's not leaving
you've been drinking woman
and I wasn't driving
I was a passenger seat yes I do any
weapons in here no
there you go you have his ID by chance
okay
[Music]
so what started the fight
so you have no idea what started
fast I don't know
yeah we have been drinking I've been
drinking
tea drinking too all right I've been
drinking I wasn't driving I was in the
Super Speed and jumped out
the shit out of me and that dude pulled
over and saw the whole goddamn that's
why
I'm over it I'm over it
so where are you bruises
are you here
that arm
anything else
okay I'm gonna take pictures with your
arm and your face we do have medical
coming
I don't need medical oh they're going to
check you out anyway that's our problem
it's fine I don't need it
um how you gonna get out of here though
it depends on our investigation
so you're willing to press charges I'm
pressing charges
so what kind of alcohol will everybody
drinking I was drinking uh some beer I
drank two beers and a couple shots of
Fireball Fireball do you have anything
else in here Fireball no Fireball it's
all gone no I threw it out the fucking
window how far back
I don't know maybe 10 miles
so about Pastor rest area about did you
see the Dairy Queen
so you got out here he got out
trucker said he saw one slap
punch okay from what he's uh yeah
I want to
but he has no ID
I'm not trying to blame anything on her
but she ended up drinking and she said
she doesn't drink liquor and she's
we got a bottle of Fire Bottle a
fireball back in um
as soon as we hit um New Mexico coming
on Texas and um
we're supposed to be going California
and having a good time and touching him
forget our past it just so you guys
thought drinking be a good way to do it
yeah
it isn't like that it's just
you hit her
truck is all you've hit did she hit you
after that or prior to that like yes I
mean like look like this blood's old
like it was like like we literally were
up the road about two two three miles
before this happened and she wanted to
pull over and I because she kept hitting
me and I was like begging her to please
stop and she kept hitting me and like
man I put on my shirt from it so once
when was
there's a alleged Kitty what was it yes
about three miles back
we gotta call it the two two four yeah
well I'm gonna go talk to him so go
ahead just stay there man
and I wanted to follow her out because I
didn't know what she was going to do at
like I don't know because I haven't ever
seen anything like this before I've
never seen Nikki this before like how
like after 16 years like we have a
daughter together I haven't ever seen it
like this before
all right
medical coming so much have we actually
had to drink because I'm smelling a lot
of alcohol yeah I'm sure sure I've had
about four or five shots
and what else that's it don't work no
beer I've had a
tomato a tomato a tomato okay Budweiser
but I wasn't driving okay well both of
you guys said you weren't driving so
somebody was driving yes sir and we'll
figure out who it is how tall are you
five nine how tall is she five five
eight five seven yeah who would drive it
all right what you mean
[Applause]
thank you
so you only saw one hit
she was on the floor man where was he at
it
he never saw anybody in the car though I
can't see anybody in the car all right
give me that back because if neither one
of them says they're driving yeah I
can't tell you because still got her
teeth yeah
needed a piece of paper it was a lunch
received okay I don't need a litter I
can chase that don't worry about it
don't worry about that
we'll figure it out
appreciate you stopping a little bit
more information and see if those two
separated yeah I appreciate you doing
what you're doing man no problem now we
got to figure out
who we're driving all right
[Applause]
foreign
steak
um
but we will find out exactly who did
what but I get another unit coming
so we'll go from there I I mean in my
opinion
she was probably defending herself at
one point yeah but that's just my
opinion you guys can find that out well
we'll get statements from both of them
and but neither one said they were
driving yeah
we'll go from there
all right I appreciate you stopping yeah
did you have help coming so anytime you
want to take off you want me to wait and
tell you all right let's get here I'm
good
I don't think she'll give me any issues
yeah she seems like a sweet girl I mean
she's you know a little maybe a little
rougher in there yeah she's definitely
you know she nobody deserves that yeah
not at all the phone number you called
from and if I have any more questions I
can call you back yes
hey bud you okay yeah
you wanna put your feet out here just
sit right there
hi sir my name is Cricket I'm an EMT
with Torrance County Fire Department
so I just want to check you out it looks
like you're completing pretty bad yeah
okay uh did she just hit you in the nose
yeah
this is my partner Chris he's trying to
get some Bibles on you so we can you
guys want to pull him out or is that
good
practice yeah do you mind walking them
I'm sorry I actually have the hospital
I have mesh stuff inside of my I'm sorry
my ass because the information so it's
hard for me to walk so that sounds awful
yeah it's awful yeah it's awful so sorry
before we walk in your father I'm gonna
just pat you down a little bit
thank you
I don't have anything on me no you're
good I just gotta check in here another
person okay turn this way a little bit
yeah yeah there you go
thanks man I appreciate your preparation
yeah okay let's get it all figured out
okay okay
okay
okay bud what's your first name
amen
are your feet too hot you're good okay
we'll figure it out but no worries
let's go one to ten how about your feet
I mean like here are some questions
I I just want her to go to jail
he gave me some safety solution for some
antibiotics
when you were in the hospital what was
your heart rate
um it was it was a little high because
of the infection okay it was like 120
okay and normally I think my heart
rate's like 70 or 80 I think
so your your heart rate right now it's
in the 130s yeah so yeah so it's
definitely a little bit worrisome so
we're gonna look at your heart real
quick yes so I can yeah
I just I have to do use diligence and
make sure that
I suggest you get checked out by a
doctor only because of the fact that
your nose she hit you pretty hard I'm
not gonna lie you're intoxicated okay
which is a natural blood thinner yes
okay so your heart rate's pretty up
there okay it could be because of your
anxiety it could be because
situation it could be because of the
systems so that's my recommendations
[Applause]
Los Angeles and I have a prescription
because they give me a a uh IV
antibiotic last night they said to wait
24 hours and wait 48 hours to fill this
thing out of this you know this should
be put into whatever you think
Perfection yeah they even told me to
wait 48 hours so
so I like I said I'm not saying you have
to be transferred today by an ambulance
but I would suggest you definitely get
checked
and trans because it could be possibly
broken yeah it's it's possibly
okay so it doesn't feel like making
things like I don't think it's broken it
could be a fracture it could be a lot of
things so I always suggest you get
checked out by a hospital but I
understand if you don't want to okay um
like that
I have a skull fraction
so the biggest thing is
he's not going anywhere no I'm not
freezing anything okay so I need to know
do you know where you're at yes I am
yeah I got to go yeah because I'm about
140 miles under three miles Albuquerque
you know what state you're in New Mexico
okay do you know uh what town you left
back there
um uh Santa Rosa okay you know what year
it is yes
so right now it is over here I can take
you to the hospital by ambulance or you
can stay here it's up to you nobody's
staying here truck's being towed yeah
there's no car yeah it's up to you're
probably going to go with that these
lovely stuff so unless you go to the
hospital unless you go to the hospital
interested
we didn't say that
no no I'm not I'm not saying you're not
being arrested you're not being arrested
or you're being arrested first we need
to take care of your medical what the
hell well now I'm fine I'm here at the
hospital like okay I I went yesterday
and I was planning on going to the
hospital to California
okay so if you're not going to go with
us that's perfectly fine I'm gonna have
you sign our tablet
stating that I informed you of your
risks of not going to the hospital okay
ah being hit so hard you could have a
brain injury you could have all kinds of
things Ah that's why I always suggest
that you get checked out okay uh if you
deal with you when you're awake and then
when you're unconscious
so at this point since you're an idiot
is your right to refusalem Medical
transform okay but at this point I don't
want to refuse anything immediately it's
not going to make it look bad
I just
have it because
okay
I'm fine okay so I'm gonna have you sign
my tablet what do you have insurance
I've seen them you have Cigna okay out
of Tennessee okay awesome so I'm gonna
take these off I'm gonna have to sign my
tablet okay and then we're going to get
out of your hair and you get it
you still alive yeah okay probably more
Mutual companion it's definitely what it
looks like so we're gonna have to we're
gonna drop her off for one hand or more
you already I think we drop him off to
the other end of Moriarty and the car
gets towed yeah all right okay
take him out of cups
I'm a little uncomfortable with that but
yeah
um you need to sign uh
and he needs to sign yeah one of you
guys needs to sign because he's in your
customers
I'm not ready to take him out of cups
yet no you're good I can't even stand on
my own two feet it's windy out here so
rocks from a pockets
let's have you sit down for just another
minute okay yes sir I appreciate you
buddy what part of Tennessee Nashville
yeah oh nice wow sorry you're good take
your time I used to live outside of
Chattanooga
operations
well you're still unconsciousness
because you're the teams just because of
the nature of the call okay you're not
you're good just just keep being cool
with us and we'll figure out what we can
do okay
I don't either yeah but like
well I recommend you guys for trying to
start over but sometimes doesn't work
out yeah throw your feet in there real
quick I'm gonna shut this door for a
minute and then we'll come back and talk
okay all right you good all right
foreign
so since you guys both been drinking
There's issues with the car we're taking
that right so we're gonna give you guys
separate rides into town do you have
money
no does she have money no yeah she does
yeah okay uh do you have
a bag or something you want to take with
you so I'm going to jail no we're taking
you into town what does that mean sir
like we're taking you to somewhere
that's not the middle of fucking nowhere
so you can have somewhere to go
can I talk to her
uh please to do what what's your name
[Music]
did you guys have phones
um I'm not inclined to what you guys
I don't think it's a good idea okay so
we're gonna get you somewhere where you
can figure out what you want to do from
there
no you're being released but not
together we're not gonna take you guys
to the same place
oh I need to know where she's doing huh
I didn't even know where she's going
well that's up to her if she wants you
to know can you ask her please yeah what
in the Jeep do you want to take I don't
just want her well you can't do that
that's not on the table so
option flip-flops what color are they
they have velcos trap okay watch your
knee
okay thank you
um
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
well for right now you're gonna you're
walking you're talking and you're all
right
all right I'm giving you no contact
order with him for 24 hours
without the alcohol first I am I know
and I said I've been drinking yeah no
you guys need to if you guys have issues
get the fuck away from each other that's
what you guys been drinking I know I'll
call number one all right we'll let you
know where everybody
I'll contact the officers I'll give you
information okay all right
thank you